Let’s summarise some of the key things that
we have learned about getting images from
the world into a computer where we can manipulate
them with MATLAB.
We have looked at a number of examples about
how we can load images from a file; load images
live from a camera; load images from somebody
else’s camera, a web camera attached to
the internet somewhere on the planet; how
to load frames from a movie file and we can
even load frames from an online internet service
like Google Earth.
What you will notice about all of these different
approaches is that there’s some common patterns
here. We create an image source object that
might be a video camera object or an access
web camera object or movie object and then
we use one of the methods of that object,
the grab method, to obtain the next image
from that image source. So we are able to
grab images a diversity of image sources,
using software which varies only very, very
little.
Now once we have the image into the MATLAB
environment it is represented by a matrix;
by a rectangular array of numbers. Every element
within that array represents the intensity
of light at the corresponding point in the
real world.
We refer to these elements as picture elements,
which is often contracted to pixel. The position
of a pixel is defined by two coordinates.
The horizontal coordinate which I denote by
the symbol u, is the distance from the left-hand
edge, and the vertical coordinate which I
define by the symbol v, is defined as the
distance from the top left-hand corner.
MATLAB is a computational environment for
dealing with matrices, and the convention
for matrices is that we index them using the
row index first followed by the column index.
Now the row is the vertical coordinate and
the column is the horizontal coordinate. So
there is a flip here between the normal way
that we represent the coordinates in a rectangular
frame or in a graph. Normally we would reference
the horizontal coordinate followed by the
vertical coordinate—we would write u,v as
the coordinate of a pixel. In MATLAB, because
we are indexing into a matrix we have to reverse
that so we would write v,u.
Now this is confusing and it is a bit of a
trap for people who are just starting out.
It is really important to remember that the
coordinates when you are indexing a matrix
are reversed compared to the coordinates that
you would use when you think about a two dimensional
plane.